You already know that we can view
multiplication as repeated addition.
So, if we had 2 times 3 (2 × 3), we could literally
view this as 3 2's being added together.
So it could be 2 + 2 + 2.
Notice this is [COUNTING: 1, 2] 3 2's.
And when you add those 2's together, you get 6.
What we're going to introduce you to
in this video is the idea of repeated multiplication –
a new operation that really can be
viewed as repeated multiplication.
And that's the operation of taking an 'exponent.'
And it sounds very fancy.
But we'll see with a few examples
that it's not too bad.
So now, let's take the idea of
2 to the 3rd power (2^3) –
which is how we would say this.
(So let me write this down
in the appropriate colors.)
So 2 to the 3rd power. (2^3.)
So you might be tempted to say,
"Hey, maybe this is 2 × 3, which would be 6."
But remember, I just said
this is repeated multiplication.
So if I have 2 to the 3rd power, (2^3),
this literally means multiplying 3 2's together.
So this would be equal to,
not 2 + 2 + 2, but 2 × ...
(And I’ll use a little dot to signify multiplication.)
... 2 × 2 × 2.
Well, what's 2 × 2 × 2?
Well that is equal to 8.
(2 × 2 × 2 = 8.)
So 2 to the 3rd power is equal to 8. (2^3 = 8.)
Let's try a few more examples here.
What is 3 to the 2nd power (3^2)
going to be equal to?
And I'll let you think about that for a second.
I encourage you to pause the video.
So let's think it through.
This literally means multiplying 2 3's.
So let's multiply 3 –
(Let me do that in yellow.)
Let's multiply 3 × 3.
So this is going to be equal to 9.
Let’s do a few more examples.
What is, say, 5 to the – let's say –
5 to the 4th power (5^4)?
And what you'll see here is
this number is going to get
large very, very, very fast.
So 5 to the 4th power (5^4) is going to be
equal to multiplying 4 5's together.
So 5^4 = 5 × 5 × 5 × 5.
Notice, we have [COUNTING: 1, 2, 3] 4 5's.
And we are multiplying them.
We are not adding them.
This is not 5 × 4.
This is not 20.
This is 5 × 5 × 5 × 5.
So what is this going to be?
Well 5 × 5 is 25. (5 × 5 = 25.)
25 × 5 is 125. (25 × 5 = 125.)
125 × 5 is 625. (125 × 5 = 625.)